the death of a salesman might be a great
play but it's far from the truth about
what's happening in the workforce today
if you look at the US economy you have
about one in nine people in the US
workforce are in sales sales that is
their job is to sell stuff they're
selling wholesale seafood or consulting
services or motorcycles but if you look
at those other eight and nine eight nine
people in the workforce they don't have
sales in their job title they don't have
sales on their business card but they're
spending an enormous amount of their
time selling in a broader sense they're
persuading influencing convincing
cajoling we have data showing that
people are spending on average about
forty percent of their time on the job
in this thing that I call somewhat
clumsily non sales selling you're
selling but the cash registers not
ringing you're selling but money's not
changing hands you're selling but the
denomination is in dollars it's time
effort attention and energy that's a big
amount of time and one of the
conclusions that you get from looking at
both the labor market data and some
interesting ways that people describe
their own work is that today like it or
not we're all in sales first of all the
there a couple there a couple
interesting things here one of them I
already noted which is that people are
spending on average as I said about 40%
of their time on the job persuading
influencing convincing cajoling what's
interesting is that if you look at
actual sales sales in the United States
is about one out of nine but the labor
markets around the world seem all to
converge around this number in Japan
it's about one in eight in the UK it's
about one in ten in the EU it's about 13
percent so despite having this
incredible communications and
information firepower at our fingertips
it seems like the economies of the world
still need a certain portion of people
simply to sell stuff and this idea that
sales people would be rendered obsolete
that we were that the internet would
create the Death of a Salesman just
hasn't happened we did a really
interesting survey of about 7,000 adult
full-time workers where they said
they're spending enormous amounts of
time on the job in this thing called non
sale selling now what is that that means
that they are an individual who's trying
to get their boss to free up resources
for
project they're selling you're a boss
trying to get employees to do something
different or do something in a different
way you're selling you come to a meeting
and pitch an idea you're selling and
it's a big part of how we spend their
time what's also interesting is we ask
people to talk about how important that
aspect of their work was to their
overall effectiveness and what was very
interesting about that is that people
rated the importance of it of that task
of non sales selling very very high
indeed in excess of the amount of time
they were doing it so what what we got
from people were saying yeah this is a
big part about what I do but in order to
be effective on the job I actually have
to do it a little bit more